actor producer director won an
Outstanding Supporting Actor in a comedy
series for Barry you can see that on HBO
Sundays at 10:30 Eastern it's season 2 a
place a gene Cousineau an eccentric
acting teacher who is revered by his
students is that a good student I mean
he's had a good description of gene yeah
he in in the classroom he's an emperor
in real life he tries out for the guy
third in line okay you know he he's
trying to make it and can't and of
course it's Henry Winkler but a bear a
Bill Hader is the star he's a serial
killer who decides that his calling is
really acting right he followed a mark
through a door he is a is a hired gun
you know and the the mark happened to be
in an acting class and bill said oh my
gosh
I don't want to kill people anymore I
want to be an actor so he he has to be
in the dark out of the light as a serial
killer now he wants to be in the light
with the spotlight on him it's pretty
crazy do you remember when you first
read the script yes I do I do i I was I
left an estate planning meeting on
Ventura Boulevard and I was driving down
a Ventura Boulevard thinking about a
black-and-white cookie from B's bakery
and this tree and I got a phone call and
they said well bill hader wants to meet
you I want bill hader
and it's on HBO nerwin ly HBO and I said
okay
his Dustin Hoffman on the short list
because if he is I'm not going in cuz
he's gonna get it have you lost a Dustin
before yes so many times yes
do you hate Dustin Hall I don't I don't
hate him
I'm just Holly bring out Dustin Hoffman
come on the floor next to me it's know
Dustin is a great I love his wife and
his kids are great but anyway so I said
if Dustin is up I'm not going in they
said no he's not
and so I went in and many months later
after auditioning I got it what do
people say when they see you you are so
short that's a big thing they say no
they say thank you for all of the years
of happiness and the laughter and and
then people know me for different things
happy days scream Adam Sandler movies
there I mean there really are sections
then Arrested Development
aa night shift night oh I love night
shift Michael Keaton yeah he's great but
you know the movie still holds up I mean
it is still a funny movie
Ron Howard said to me you can play
either role and so I thought well I've
played the Fonz for 10 years I'm gonna
play Ritchie and that's what I did I
played Chuck but how big did you realize
how big you were with happy days with
like how famous you were after a while
you cannot miss it because you know it
was very scary to walk on the street
because people wanted to take my socks
off without ever taking off my shoes
they I mean they really wanted a piece
of whatever I was wearing or my hair was
it like boy band where it was big it was
a hundred and 26 countries
I got 55,000 letters a week uh I got
jewelry I got you know like little
crucifixes a little bears girls would
take their jewelry off and this is what
I learned from my fan mail
Jewish girls do not send their jewelry
through the mail but it was it was very
big and I went to Dodger Stadium I took
my children to see a Dodger game and
they put my picture on the diamond
vision in the middle of the field and
55,000 people started chanting Andrey
Andrey Fonzie Fonzie so the security
guards got me and put me back in my car
and we listen to the game on the
a home and I went into my daughter's
room and I said so II we made a deal
that some of your clothing was gonna get
like on a hanger before we left for the
game she looked at me and she said I
will never chant your name I'm not even
gonna whisper your name Wow yeah I was a
big guy in my house
yeah you were you were I was trying to
tell people what it was like I was a
senior in high school way and I remember
in Ohio and what what city Mason Ohio
so outside of Cincinnati yeah one of the
great restaurants in the country what is
now in Cincinnati and was when I first
started going around the country and I'm
interrupting your story because I'm such
a great story to come right back to the
story I'm not kidding okay but in
Cincinnati is Boca
it's called Boca one of the best Italian
restaurants in America go ahead thank
you very much we now resume our
regularly scheduled program a kin Mason
okay I was being introduced at a
basketball game right and we went out
and you know they'd say in that guard
and then you'd go out and we did the
thumbs-up yeah we did the fonz thumbs up
in the middle of the court thank you we
lost and we never did it again no but we
did you know what I don't care about the
losing cuz I've never played basketball
but I do care about the thumbs up yeah
we spear that was that I take that as a
great compliment do you have you collect
sports memorabilia you know what I have
I have Shaq's shoe signed and I actually
used it as a canoe it is a very big shoe
and I have a ball that is signed by the
Lakers when in the 80s I had seats when
abdul-jabbar right there and again so
here is that how crazy and non sports be
I am I go backstage to see the players
of the Lakers after the game and mr.
abdul-jabbar throws a jersey at me and I
did not know he meant that I could have
it I threw it in the laundry room I'm
not kidding this was a the Happy Days
ball team we we went all across the
country playing softball at the Phillies
state stadium and the the Milwaukee
Brewers yeah and the Mets you know I
write children's books called Hank zip
stir the world's greatest underachiever
he is a dyslexic little boy who's very
funny and he is a Mets fan because they
are underachievers - and you found out
you had dyslexia when you were right I'm
31
oh you were I was 31 again my stepson
Jed was having trouble and very verbal
and smart and I kept thinking he was
just being like I was told being lazy
and finally we had him tested and
everything they said about him was true
about me a one out of five children have
some sort of learning challenge in the
world and we have to take care of those
kids because they have enormous
potential and once you somebody realizes
that you have it yeah ready Terry yeah
how about that I did nice to pee it's
hereditary so my parents who would yell
at me and ground me and be embarrassed
by me they were the ones who dated to me
he's Henry Winkler you got to see the
show Barry it's Sunday at 10:30 Eastern
on HBO with Bill Hader the supporting
cast is spectacular
they are there the Chechens and I mean
that's just it's a it's a great show and
it's a half hour so you know what you
know uz to binge on it consuming it is
there are eight episodes in the in the
first season last sunday this past
Sunday was our first of the second
and I am very very proud I mean look I
got the funds when I was 27 and I'm now
73 and Here I am on this incredible show
you always know you're on a good show
through when you walk through an airport
people will either say hey how are you
it's good to see you or I love Barry
yeah yeah or the quote lines from it
absolutely something like that or they
will go a very original could you have
handled the success of Fonzie at 21 or
22 I have figured out
honestly I've put it together there is
an emotional component to being dyslexic
you have a very low self-esteem because
you are failing at everything no
thinking how is this possible
I knew my words last night in my house
now in the classroom I have completely
forgotten when people would talk to me
about Fonzie or they you know that you
are the greatest thing or you're
wonderful and I would think this is good
and I'm feeling good but they can't
possibly be talking about me because I
know I'm a failure so I think that that
helped me with the success and and not
taking it to heart I was at the Teddy
Hotel the Roosevelt Hotel yes a teddy
bar yes I met your son Max max was with
Jonah Hill yes they grew up together
Jonah Hill now let me just say this this
is a has nothing to do with Barry but
Jonah Hill's sister beanie beanie
Feldstein is in a movie called
book-smart
that is coming out directed by Olivia
Wilde I'm telling you you are going to
be charmed out of your soul by this
movie but anyway Jonah would sit in my
house and call restaurants and pretend
he was Brad Pitt's assistant and say
Brad is coming in he
a kazoo at every at every setting and he
would do these pranks in my living room
it was funny
and I just was hoping they wouldn't call
back and find out it was me but your son
Max came up to me yeah and he wanted to
talk football yes he was like what do
you think of USC so I I'm with Sandler's
riding partner Jack giarraputo I know
jack so jack goes this guy right here is
gonna be huge and it was Jonas so Jonah
didn't even have any movies out I don't
think at the time and all of a sudden
Jonah comes over with Max and they start
talking football yeah and I'm going this
guy is gonna be a big like I I'm saying
to say I wonder what he was gonna be in
you know what that you never know you
cannot judge a book cover I know but I
just remember he was our son just
directed his third movie and is editing
it for a Ridley Scott's company as has
he put you in a movie he oh yes yes
he did they were all student films okay
he has never actually hired me with hard
cash would it be great if he hired
Dustin Hoffman instead of you what do
you know what that would really piss me
off but you know what he did do he
directed me for my audition for Barry he
was there he looked over the the scenes
he made me do the scenes for him and
then he would criticize he would
critique me oh well and then I went the
next day and auditioned but isn't that
great that your son gets to that level
where he feels confident enough to be
able to say to you dad yes I'm gonna
treat you as an actor he is a wise
fellow my daughter Zoey is a beautiful
teacher and now the mother of three and
Jed is in business and has two beautiful
daughters Barry Sundays at ten at ten
yeah ten Barry is a 10 10 on HBO will
you bring him down 10:30 yes I did and I
apologize just you I think so if your
listeners how many are there there's all
in any Millions 1010 on HBO we go
door-to-door princey I would go Jordan
Jill I'm the one that needs to go do the
door because I paid put 10:30 there
because I
gotten that wrong no no but III actually
have no pride I would you would
door-to-door to all of your fans away
where are they located
they're all over the world it's that
true yes we could be talking now to
Switzerland
we could be talking we're big and in
Switzerland I can't walk down the street
since when do you know what I studied
French in Switzerland and being so
dyslexic I learned one word bibliothèque
oh that means the library yeah thank you
yeah thank you I just remember I'm a man
I'm a man of many languages we evoke
hershiser shame livre No yeah but
remember in a cootie a rape ate a Wow
yeah I don't know what the hell you're
exactly it's I said Jerry did you notice
that we were thinking the same I I have
I love the color green yeah you know why
I left color I really do you look great
yeah at the end my pants agree I don't
miner green - yeah well they kind of
look grayish they're greenish they're
green grayish the Dennis had one
question for you what is the question
for henry winkler it's Sunday at 10:00
you've got millions of fans in is like
one question well on behalf of them we
usually don't get to ask anything okay
they said could we ask you one question
okay mr. Winkler yes sir on behalf of
all Happy Days fans yes when you were an
actor during or after the first season
Happy Days what were you told was the
reason
Gavin O'Herlihy Chuck Cunningham was not
going to be in the future the show
Ritchie had a brother named Chuck hey
here's the truth the actual story here's
the truth first of all this is how great
and loyal the Fonz is he watches Barry
at ten o'clock on Sunday night on HBO
okay I'm not kids'll not 10:30 he calls
me up he said I want to tell you
something that is like that is a great
character I love him and you know he's
he's a funny guy okay here's the truth
there was a there was in the first Chuck
who left because he didn't want to be an
actor he got the job and then decided he
didn't want to be an actor and left then
Gavin came in Gavin O'Hurley a wonderful
wonderful actor that Ron then used in
other
movies of his never used me except for
tonight ship but he and the reason was
he went upstairs and never came down
because I became the big brother and
they they didn't have room for two big
brothers so they wrote him out of the
show four and that's the actual reason
yeah yeah some people said it was body
odor and I know now there's such a it
was not who came up with the accent for
Fonzie I did it came out of my little
mouth but but you just know this is
during the audition I walked in and I
have long hair down to my shoulders and
a gigantic sweat stain that looked like
the Hudson River was flowing under my
arm and I walked in and I just I made a
decision that the guy reading with me
Pasquale was going to sit down and I was
gonna be the only one standing then they
said they go to the mirror comb your
hair I said you know what I have made a
decision I'm not gonna comb my hair
because every actor who's played a part
like this combs their hair or had a comb
in their back pocket so I'll do anything
but I won't call my hair but phones
didn't need to because the hair that's
right and that director said go comb
your hair so I had to be true to myself
and true to the being a professional I
walk to the mirror pulled out my Gorman
at 1:00 hey I don't look at that he's
perfect
whoa and I just found out that Barry is
on Sunday nights at 10 it's a 10 o'clock
on HBO Sunday night and you know what
honestly we have mentioned it many many
times and and kind of like as a joke but
as a producer I know you must mention
everything three times at least or it
doesn't go in to the the millions of you
viewers you get something like are they
all men no there were some women out
there look at me women of course are
tuning in for this you know what you're
not the best looking guy in the room
that is true me no no no we're 27 yes
but it's kind of gone now yeah but women
had to be throwing themselves at you
well they threw things at me
cause they there were panties there were
there were yes but I returned them yes
yes yeah it's awesome to have you it
thank you and really very happy this is
my first time no it's it's wonderful
thank you please tell your son that I
said hello hello and I I do remember
that he came up and he just wanted to
talk to us he football I will well you
know now my favorite team is the
Seahawks because we knew Pete Carroll
yeah
when he was at USC so that's where max
went yeah
and I got to stand on the on the field
and they were so big that unless they
stood like this with their arms and
there was a hole for me to look at him I
saw nothing I just heard like a herd of
human being running down the field
Reggie was the og Bush Reggie Bush man a
very skinny legs but boy could he run
when Dale white yeah
mr. white yeah absolutely
thanks for coming thank Matt liner Matt
liner
he's Henry Winkler I am actor producer
director and it's Barry and it's 10
o'clock on Sunday nights on HBO thank
you for having worked for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]